las vegas and the u.s travel association
kicking off the city's first
international trade show since the
beginning of the pandemic as you know
this is major for our town because we
depend on those visitors pioneer joining
us now live from the convention center
to share more about this impact bianca
good morning to you
good morning heather so we know that las
vegas was one of the official
destinations for conventions and a big
one is back today it is the
international travel show that is coming
here it's called the ipw and it's
actually a model to help restart
international travel and shows
across the united states a matter of
fact right here on this sign and the
video that's in the convention center
they've been showcasing various cities
like san francisco and orlando so that's
what the ipw uh trade show is about it's
an international travel trade show they
bring together travel exhibitors travel
buyers journalists and government
representatives from across the country
and so people come from across the globe
to again see what the us has to offer so
offer so past shows have generated more
than 5 billion dollars in future travel
and that's according to their website
since we are fighting our way through
the pandemic the show requires attendees
to show proof of vaccination or negative
covet tests taken within 72 hours of
check-in and again the way they run
things here they hope that that
influences other conventions and shows
across the u.s now this is not the only
big show that's coming of course this
one is really focused on international
travelers but we got some more
conventions that are coming up in the
following weeks matter of fact there's
going to be the international wireless
communications expo that's coming at the
end of september
and then also american rental
association and then a national hardware
show that's all coming in the next month
so again it's a good sign that jobs and
travel coming back here to las vegas
valley reporting live from the
convention center bianca holman 8 news
now